well you want to know whether you're
finding the scale factor from this
figure on the left to this figure on the
right or if you're going from the figure
on the right to the figure on the left
so that's very important is the
direction that you're scaling the figure
and the formula I like to remember this
is just a simple way of doing it is just
think about new / old so if I'm going
from this triangle to this triangle this
is my new triangle and I'm going to
divide by the old triangle now what you
want to do if the figures are similar
and they tell you that in the problem
you want to match up the corresponding
side so say for example if I'm comparing
four and ten I'm going from four to ten
what am i multiplying by to get from
four to ten that's my scale factor so
the easiest way to do this would just be
to take the new length which is ten
divided by the old length which is four
and you can see that's giving us a scale
factor of five divided by two which is
two and a half so this is going to be
two-and-a-half times you know the scaled
okay so the size are two and a half
times longer now the one way that you
can tell your fear on the right track is
if the scale factor is greater than one
then that means it's an enlargement it's
getting bigger so enlargement now if the
scale factor is less than one okay like
a half or third or something like that
then it's a reduction it's getting
smaller so if we're going from this
figure to this figure
okay now this would be the new length
that's for the old length was ten now
we're looking at a scale factor of 2/5
and you can see 2/5 is less than 1 so
you can see that this is a reduction and
it makes sense because you can see this
figures you know a lot smaller but
notice that these are reciprocals of
each other so even if you mix it up and
you say well I got to fist but it
doesn't make sense this figure is larger
I'm going from here to here it should be
you know all you have to do is just take
the reciprocal and you realize all the
scale factor is 5 halves so that's how
you work with scale factor it's very
simple again just pay attention to the
direction that you're going and use the
formula new divided by old and you got
it so subscribe to the channel check out
more math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon